[Music]
on this Saturday night reaction to us
retaliation in the Middle East The
Barrage of attacks and the fears of
wider conflict is on the brink this is a
powder K the whole Middle East and there
are too many people running around with
matches as the White House warns of even
more strikes on Iran back targets plus
Syria and Iraq's condemnation vowing
catastrophic
consequences Declassified details Canada
under criticism for letting thousands of
former Nazis into the country it's
personal these individuals eradicated
all of my family what newly released
documents reveal about problematic
policies trans policy protest
demonstrators fight back against
Alberta's attack on gender rights a
stunning sight holding Galactic secrets
in this amazing detail that was
previously inaccessible the mindblowing
spiral galaxy images and what they tell
us global national with far Asser
reporting tonight n gcha good evening
and thanks for joining us dangerous
developments and fears of an escalating
conflict in the Middle East tonight
after the US Unleashed its Firepower
launching a wave of strikes inside Syria
and Iraq Washington calls it retaliation
for last Sunday's drone attack that
killed three US soldiers both Syria and
Iraq are condemning the attacks warning
of dire
consequences the US targeted seven
locations reportedly wiping out supply
lines security facilities and weapon
storage sites connected to Iran's
revolutionary guard and Iranian backed
militias us defense secretary Lloyd
Austin says this is the start while US
President Joe Biden warned if you harm
an American the US will respond the US
Envoy in Baghdad has been summoned by
the Iraqi foreign ministry tonight with
both Iraq and Syria saying the US has
violated their sovereignty Karen
liberman has our top story
tonight 85 targets hit in a series of US
air strikes against Iranian proxies in
Iraq and Syria the beginning of what's
been called a multi-tiered response by
President Joe Biden's Administration to
the attack that killed three American
Service members at a base in Jordan
nearly a week ago basically the
nefarious per party in this is Iran and
the West is trying in one way or another
to retaliate when there's an attack but
particularly try to constrain Iran's
capability to alter the balance of power
in that region although the strikes
appear calibrated in order to avoid
stoking a broader War the White House
has signaled more is coming our response
began today wrote the president late
Friday it will continue at times and
places of our choosing I believe those
who are attacking us bases have to know
that they are actually pouring oil into
the fire this is a powder K the whole
Middle East and there are too many
people running around with matches the
Iraqi government condemned the deadly
strikes saying they will bring
disastrous consequences to the region
Iran meanwhile called them another
strategic Mistake by the American
government which experts say risk a
further escalation of a widening Middle
East conflict every day uh where the
region isn't in Total War uh is a good
day uh so it's very much a day-to-day uh
type of operation to limit hostilities
to push back adversaries to address
threats as they fly earlier Friday the
Iranian president said Iran would not
start a war but if a cruel Force wants
to bully it the Islamic Republic of Iran
will give a strong response and they
want to push the West out they want to
Prevail over the Saudi Le Sunni block
within the region they want want to
eliminate Israel and they don't want to
pay a cost uh now of course the threat
that they'll pay a cost is where we are
eyes are now on Tran to see if and how
they will respond to the latest
escalations for Iran the US is Satan and
Israel is its to and and I'm not even
sure that the creation of Palestinian
state would come necessar the irion
into behaving in a different way towards
the us or towards the West Karen
liberman Global News
Toronto and breaking news in the Middle
East tonight the US and UK launched
another round of air strikes on houthi
rebels in Yemen the Pentagon says 36
houthi Targets in 13 different locations
were struck sites said to be holding
weapons and equipment the houthis have
used to attack shipping and navy vessels
in the Red Sea for months this marks the
third wave of strikes by British and US
forces on the houthis in retaliation for
the armed groups aggression in the Red
Sea in Gaza at least 18 people including
women and children were killed by
Israeli bombardments targeting the
southern city of
Rafa that's the aftermath of overnight
strikes one of gaza's last remaining
safe zones the city is home to more than
a million people who fled attacks in
other parts of the Palestinian Territory
located on the border with Egypt Rafa is
one of few cities in southern Gaza that
Israeli ground forces have not yet
reached but Israel now says it is
expanding military operations around the
town newly released documents are
revealing more about Canada's policies
around letting Nazis into this country
and letting them stay there's been
renewed pressure on the federal
government to release more information
in the wake of last year's Standing
Ovation in Parliament for a man who
fought in a notorious Nazi unit now
we're learning more about former prime
minister p Pierre Trudeau's take Abigail
Beeman reports on the documents and what
those demanding their release want done
about
it we have that famous quote uh that
says None is too many Annette Wild Goose
holds a luggage tag from her late
mother's trip aboard the MS St Louis a
ship full of Jewish refugees fleeing
Germany in 1939 turned away by Nations
including Canada there's a stark
juxtaposition for her between Canada's
attitude toward WS Jews before and
during the second world war and new
information about how our country
accepted Nazis after these individuals
eradicated all of my family so I have no
cousins aunts and
uncles the Scandal over a former member
of the Nazi waffin SS receiving a
standing ovation in the House of Commons
last fall renewed a push by Jewish
groups just showed an astonishing
historical ignorance and sort of
reinforce the need to get the records
out the now more complete version of the
rodal report details then Justice
Minister Pierre Trudeau's take on a
laian Canadian known as subject F
convicted in absentia by the Soviet
Union as the captain of a firing squad
which murdered
5,128 Jews in 1967 Pierre Trudeau was
against stripping subject F's
citizenship writing the applicants obl
ation is to satisfy the court that he is
of good character he is not required to
satisfy the court that he at no time in
his past committed an appropriate act he
was worried that people who came from
those countries would feel that their
own citizenship would be in Jeopardy
because of uh an attempt to prosecute NY
war criminals but in fact that wasn't
the case it punctures Canada's
self-image in the uh conduct of World
War II and in the aftermath there are
more details yet to be released
including the names of 240 suspected
Nazi war criminals this is uh both uh an
important part of the historical record
but also uh one that has uh implications
around privacy uh around uh Community
cohesion someone like myself who is part
of the second generation have a
responsibility to see this through
concerned about some applicants from
places like Gaza and Iran David matus
wants Canada to learn from the past and
there's lots of modern perpetrators who
like the Nazis before them are trying to
get into Canada to to see AA we
certainly need to protect ourselves
better than we did at the the time of
the Nazi inlux Abigail ban global news
Ottawa in Alberta there were rallies in
the province's two largest cities to
oppose Premier Danielle Smith's sweeping
new regulations on gender identity her
policy will put thousands of Children at
Risk she will risk their health their
mental health and their very lives for
her own political
gamesmanship Alberta NDP leader Rachel
notley joined protesters in Edmonton who
rallied simultaneously with another
demonstration in Calgary both Gatherings
expressing anger over Smith's newly
announced plan to restrict important
procedures for transgender youth The
Province aims to ban gender reassignment
surgery for those 17 and under and
hormone therapies for anyone 15 and
under that's on top of a slew of consent
requirements for miners opponents
including medical experts have
criticized the regulations as uninformed
and harmful our chief political
correspondent David Akin spoke with
Alberta's Premier about her proposal he
has more on how she's defending the move
David well nether Daniel Smith won a
majority government last May in an
election where the dominant issues were
healthc care and the economy and almost
nothing was said about regulating trans
gender youth I say almost nothing you'll
remember Smith had to disqualify a
candidate who compared transgender youth
to feces and cookies and yet though
regulating transgender youth was not in
the UCP platform Smith is now saying
that she's going to introduce
legislation later this year that goes
farther than New Brunswick Spain higs or
Saskatchewan Scott Mo to limit
transgender youth's participation in
sports what they call themselves and
their health care options
we felt like it was important for us to
make sure that we had guidelines that
were understandable and acceptable we we
believe the starting point should be
that uh kids should not be making
irreversible decisions among the most
controversial parts of the plan a rule
requiring teachers to notify parents if
a student arrives in class asking to be
recognized using a different gender I
think that we have to have families
involved in those decisions from from
the very beginning so that they can
support them and just as higs and mo
found stiff opposition to their policies
Smith too can expect to find a fight
outgoing Alberta NDP leader Rachel
notley condemned the proposals and new
Democrats and liberals in Ottawa found
fault with what Smith is proposing
particularly around the rule requiring
teachers to inform parents against a
student's wishes there is a small
minority of kids David who literally
fall through the cracks because when
they come out to their parents something
breaks down and I know because I've seen
the numbers on the street now the law
may be on the side of the likes of Randy
boso the liberal cabinet minister and
other opponents to that pronoun rule Mo
Saskatchewan had to invoke the
notwithstanding Clause to Charter proof
challenges to his pronoun law but public
opinion turns in a slightly different
direction a recent Angus Reed Institute
poll found more than 70% of parents
agree that they should at least be
notified about a child's change in
gender status well about 35% say parents
must also consent to new names or
pronouns nean all right David Aken in
Ottawa thanks David an influx of Mexican
citizens looking for refuge in Montreal
coming up the calls for housing and work
permits to keep up with the growing flow
of Asylum
Seekers at least 46 people have been
killed by raging forest fires in central
Chile the deadliest are in the country's
Valar region which is blanketed in Smoke
92 fires are currently burning a slow
moving snowstorm is packing a punch in
Nova
Scotia residents near downtown Halifax
were digging out today after a major
dump of snow overnight 30 to 40 cm is
expected throughout the weekend in
Central Nova Scotia while up to 80 cm is
forecast in eastern parts of the
province Canada has seen a steady influx
of of Asylum Seekers over the past few
years there has been an increasing
number of claims coming from Mexican
citizens since the Trudeau government
scrapped a Visa requirement for Mexican
Travelers in late 2016 there was hope
last Winter's closure of The Unofficial
roxom Road border crossing south of
Montreal would slow the flow but as
Gloria Enriquez tells us that hasn't
been the case aruro Nava is fresh off a
flight from Mexico City ready to start a
new life in Canada the petrochemical
engineer traveled on a tourist visa but
as soon as he landed at Montreal's
Trudeau airport he requested Refugee
status he says there's a lot of talk in
Mexico about how supportive Canada is to
refugees though he admits he didn't have
much information about what the process
entails Nava is one of thousands of
Mexicans who are coming to Quebec to
claim refugee status in 2023 Quebec
processed more than 25,000 Asylum claims
at the airport more than double the
amount of 2022 in general Asylum
requests in Quebec have exploded in the
past 2 years in 2021 Quebec received a
total of just over 10,000 requests
compared to more than 59,000 in 2023 in
2021 there were more than 1300 requests
from Mexican citizens in 2023 the
government received received more than
15,000 requests a high number of people
with Haitian and Colombian citizenship
also requested Refugee status in the
province those who land at Trudeau
airport and have nowhere to stay are
sent here the regional program for
settlement and integration of Asylum
Seekers known as prid Elizabeth Valencia
says it has been harder than she thought
much a few blocks away from Pride us
shelter is the welcome Collective they
say they've seen an increase of Asylum
Seekers like Nava and Valencia coming
through the airport a major issue is
that their work permits don't come right
away pushing many to request financial
assistance for the first 15 days of 2024
Quebec's labor Ministry says there have
been nearly 10,000 requests that's an
average of 656 per day an estimated 30%
come from Asylum Seekers Melissa CL says
the government should issue work permits
upon arrival
just like it did for Ukrainian refugees
that's going to mean that so many
families thousands of families won't
have to go on welfare in the first place
federally funded assistance would also
help she says to navigate a massive
change and the reality of a new and
unknown
life Gloria Enriquez Global News
Montreal ahead is it a case of profit
over patients the pharmacare deal
raising red flags over consumer
Choice there was a major shakeup in
Canadian pharmacare this week with
manual lifee announcing a deal with
grocery giant LW Shoppers Drug Mart and
lbls will become the exclusive suppliers
of so-called specialty drugs at least
one competitor is now exploring its
legal options as Mike trolle tells us
there are concerns about what it could
mean for Consumer choice
independent pharmacists count pills as
well as profit margins and they're about
to get fewer of both that's because
Insurance giant manual life has made a
deal with retail giant LW giving its
Shoppers Drug Mar chain exclusive rights
to deal 260 specialty medications to its
plan members leaving pharmacists like
Ramy suriel questioning the future of
his industry the way I see it it's uh a
deal for profit but not for patient so
again maybe I'm repeating myself but it
is the same thing I mean think patient
if we don't think patient we have lost
our Canadian Healthcare insights the
deal has raised red flags in Ottawa with
NDP MPS Don Davies and Brian Massie
asking the competition Bureau to
investigate the serious impacts that
this Arrangement could have on both
access to medication and competition
within the pharmacy sector Canada's
industry minister said the government
will be reviewing the deal you know they
don't get the message you know we we're
we're we want more competition in this
country we want more options we want
more choices so uh that's not going in
the direction we want to
see the drugs in question treat
conditions such as rheumatoid arthritis
Crohn's Ms and cancer and they're pricey
costing more than $10,000 annually and
while they make up less than 1% of Total
Drug claims they make up almost a third
of Total Drug spending in Canada manif
has said the deal with lbla will save
money but for whom we have no idea how
much they're passing on to consumers or
onto the the insurance uh payers that is
the employers and unions that sponsor
the insurance plans and how much is
being passed on to corporate Executives
in bonuses and to shareholders in
profits the fear from industry Watchers
is too fo that if it works with
specialty medications generic pills
could be next and that in turn could
lead to an American style system where a
select few pharmacies control the
majority of the market and this will
have the effect of creating a smaller
number of dominant Pharmacy chains and
very profitable insurance companies and
all of behind all of this there will be
relatively Li limited transparency bore
Healthcare which had a similar deal with
manual before being cut out has told its
members to be patient that they're now
exploring their legal options Mike like
Global News
Toronto next spiral galaxies like
they've never been seen before the
intricate images leaving astronomers in
[Music]
awe the world's most powerful telescope
just captured the most detailed images
of 19 spiral galaxies and the millions
of stars that call them home about 60%
of all galaxies are believed to be
spiral galaxies our own solar system
sits in one of the Spiral arms of the
Milky Way as Joe scarpelli explains
astronomers are in absolute awe the
images are so detailed that even
astronomers are stunned that allows us
to see this kind of previously hidden
aspect of a galaxy in this amazing
detail that was previously inaccessible
the 19 spiral galaxies were captured by
the large infrared James web Space
Telescope launched in 2021 the world's
most powerful telescope is a
collaboration between NASA the European
space agency and Canadian space agency
what we're really finally understanding
is how the gas and the Stars interact
and we can kind of see how they move
back and forth and influence each other
Eric rosolowski is a physics professor
at the University of Alberta and member
of the fangs or physics at high angular
resolution in nearby galaxies project
it's a project being worked on by an
international group of researchers which
includes rosal's team from Edmonton and
some others in Toronto they're on a
mission to understand how galaxies work
what we're trying to do is collect
observations from a variety of different
telescopes including the James Webb
Space Telescope uh to see a Galaxy in
all the possible ways we can look at a
Galaxy other astronomers are eagerly
watching their every move we need more
data is something astronomers say really
often but we say that because the
universe is a complicated place and and
you you want to capture the the richness
of what's what's there and there's a lot
more richness to capture Joel scarpelli
Global News and that is global national
for this Saturday night I'm Nara we'll
leave you tonight with a celebration of
in Toronto as NHL Allstar festivities
get underway young players and Pros
alike also gathered for the hockey
diversity alliance's inaugural
Winterfest event which works to combat
racism celebrate diversity and Inspire
change in the sport thanks so much for
watching and hope you can join us again
tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night
I